here with reaction he just came out with
a brand new book it's in bookstores as
of today beyond biden it's on amazon.com
hannity.com bookstores everywhere fox
news contributor newt gingrich um
what does kamala harris accomplish
because she's supposed to be the borders
are she never went anywhere near where
the action at the border is you know i
i've got a long list i can read off to
you and i i think you know we've got you
know literally apparently she hired a pr
team they had that disastrous phony
session video session with child actors
uh she's done nothing as borders are of
course the weird laughing that is seem
seemingly unending
goes to travel to france she comes out
with a phony french accent doesn't
resolve the issues she was supposed to
resolve involving australia so tell me
where they're successful mr speaker
because i don't see it
by the way there is a website that
has 10 hours
of kamala harris laughing
taken from all these various interviews
10 hours 10 hours
that's right if you want to punish a
friend make them watch it but it gives
you a sign of what's happening to her i
mean being the laughing vice president
is not necessarily a good thing if
that's one of your most famous
accomplishments
i think she actually accomplished
something very historic
she got cnn historically
the strongest supporter of liberal
democrats to run an entire story
pointing out that the president's team
and the vice president's team are
fighting internally in a very ferocious
way
i've never seen cnn do anything that
would be harmful to joe biden this story
was devastating and i think it starts
with a simple fact
biden's at 38 percent approval
she's a 28 percent approval
powerful people wake up in the morning
they go it can't be me
so i wonder who's doing this so the
biden people say it's all harris's fault
the harris people say you know if only
he was using her correctly and i think
you're going to see more of this kind of
backbiting because the truth is she
hasn't accomplished anything i mean
it's an embarrassment but then on the
other hand she's working with joe biden
who has accomplished almost nothing and
it's an embarrassment as you point out
just watching him in public in an
unscripted environment uh is is a little
frightening frankly to think that this
is the commander in chief and to know
that our opponents around the planet are
watching the same tv coverage
so so
i think this is
to me
this is having known a fair number of
vice presidents this is an amazing
moment for probably the worst vice
president in american history
well i mean
they have this conflict that's obviously
going on
joe's at 35 on average in in the public
approval polls she's at a whopping low
28 percent
i would say afghanistan is the reason
the economy is the reason more people
dead from covert in 2021 than 2020 is a
reason the chaos at the border inflation
the high cost of energy because of their
policies all of these issues preventable
they could fix it if they go back to the
trump policies that work we both know
that's not going to happen so now the
question is how do they dig themselves
out of this hole if they're not willing
to change
there's no evidence at all right now
that they will dig themselves out as you
know
a major liberal publication just
released a poll that shows the
republicans now ahead by 10 points in
the generic ballot which is the largest
lead they've had in 40 years yeah you
know think about it 40 years
and i think that poll actually
understates how bad it is because it
oversampled democrats and under-sampled
republicans but the fact is
they're not going to turn around
inflation they're not going to close
they don't believe in closing the border
so they're not going to close it they
don't believe in stopping crime uh so
it's going to keep going up
they don't believe in
taking any steps that would stop
inflation and frankly the idea that
somebody like buddha judge
who has had no experience is going to
solve the logistics problem is crazy so
you're going to have more americans
angry every day when americans fill up
their car or their truck they get madder
at biden and harris and i think harris
suffers more because she isn't as well
known and frankly to have her laughing
while the rest of us are suffering
is a pretty bad counterpoint and i think
just further alienates her
from most americans if you're not a
hardcore liberal you've been alienated
from kamala harris and i think basically
ended any chance she'll ever be
president
uh don't forget jennifer granholm the
energy secretary laughing too
saying what's your plan to well i said i
assumed i assumed jennifer was a
imitator of kamala but the new thing for
liberal democrats is to learn to laugh
it's not so funny for the poor and
middle class mr speaker people are
suffering
yeah they're desperate and and you know
what they're not going to go they don't
they can stop begging
opec and just ask texas alaska north
dakota and oklahoma mr speaker by the
way the book is out beyond biden
bookstores everywhere
amazon.comhannity.com sir thanks for
being with us i'm steve ducey i'm brian
killman and i'm ainsley earhardt and
click here to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis